we're still not actually inserting
weather data into the content provider
so this is a good time to talk about
bulk inserts remember that bulk insert
allows us to insert multiple rows far
more efficiently by using a database
transaction we can apply this when we
need to insert 14 days worth of weather
data into the table use the content
provider to bulk insert the vector of
content values into the database note
there are a few lines underneath the
area where you add your bulk insert code
that you can use to test displaying the
values you just inserted it'll read
those values out of the database create
content values for them and pass them
into the same display function we
already have